more than 19,000 migrants seeking asylum
in the US are waiting just across the
border in Mexico it is becoming more
difficult to enter the u.s. legally so
many are making the dangerous decision
to cross the border at least 170
migrants are missing or have died this
year
Mireya Villarreal is in Hidalgo Texas
after visiting a camp in Mexico where
migrants are waiting to enter the u.s.
desperate for a better life hundreds of
people are waiting for asylum here in
Matamoros Mexico how long have you been
here I've been waiting here 2 and 1/2
months many are sleeping on sidewalks
worried they'll be passed over if they
aren't nearby she says there's no way
she can go back to her home country that
things are much more dangerous there so
she will wait as long as it takes
here US volunteers like Melba Salazar
Lucia cross from Brownsville Texas to
feed these families she asked to raffle
off books and toys because there just
isn't enough you saw them some kids were
like grabbing two numbers two papers so
that maybe in the raffle they would get
a dog there are more than 300 and 27,000
pending applications right now for
asylum at the u.s. so it's gonna take a
long time to get through all of that
Melba tells us that she will continue to
go into Matamoros Mexico as long as it
takes delivering her toys and books
until every child gets one Tony just a
dire situation there Moriah thank you